so one of the saddest and most painful
eyes they keep telling you is you're
imagining it if you think children are
being physically mutilated in the name
of gender ideology but it's actually
real we wish it weren't we wish we're
imagining it hospitals brag about these
surgeries and we know this really
because of the founder of a Twitter
handle called Libs of tick tock
hierarchic she's reported on it
extensively of course this is infuriated
people who are dedicated to lying like
Sandy Cortez you're a liar she said
um and she called high reject that
directly so raychik decided to go pay
Sandy Cortez a visit here's how I went
on the house floor Miss navaroli are you
familiar with the account Libs of tick
tock that account posted false
information about Boston Children's
Hospital claiming that they were
providing hysterectomies
children so I am right outside the
cannon building and I'm gonna go inside
and hopefully meet AOC and ask her why
she lied about me and get some answers
[Music]
I don't think anyone's here hi hi hi uh
it's a congresswoman name no she's not
okay is a person who's in charge of
protect policy in no okay yeah so
basically she lied about me on the house
floor a couple of weeks ago so I just
wanted to ask her why she lied about me
okay give me one second okay
okay so I don't think we're gonna get to
talk to her we don't I don't know if if
she's in or not but I think that that
door slam was really telling so I don't
think they want to talk to us dear AOC
please don't lie about American citizens
love Kaya
what's so funny is that Sandy Cortez
would not exist as a public figure were
it not for social media she literally
filmed herself applying makeup and then
her staff seemed shocked that maybe this
is on video all right chick is the
founder of Libs of tick tock and the
woman you just saw in that video she
joins us now hi thank you so much for
coming on I mean did you think that she
would own up to the provable LIE she
told about you I mean she claimed that
something didn't happen that you proved
on video did happen did you think she
would admit that
AOC claimed that I lied about Boston
Children's Hospital she claimed that I
inspired a bomb threat and I absolutely
had no expectations for her to own up to
it I went to her office and I was ready
to sit down with her and get to the
bottom of this and explain it and she I
don't know if she was in the office or
not but I don't I she cowered away I
don't think she would ever face me or
ever have a discussion about it but I as
an American citizen I don't appreciate
being defamed in front of millions of
people so I wanted to confront her and
she cowered
what's I mean what and thank you for
adding details there that I should have
added in the intro she accused you of
inspiring violence of effectively a
criminal act
yeah and she is unfortunately protected
by legislative privilege so she is
allowed to lie about me in a Committee
hearing and not just that but she's
using her position of power to call on
big Tech to censor people who she
disagrees with that's what she did in
the hearing and that is really scary
it's really scary and thank you for
trying to face her directly which is a
nice thing to do in a social media age
hi Rachel Tick Tock appreciate it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight